BRADY FORREST: Hi I'm
Brady Forrest,
and welcome to Ignite.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Unfortunately, we
don't have beer this year.
You can bring that up
with the management.
But I'm just thrilled
to be here anyway.
And how are you all
enjoying I/O?
I hope you are ready
for just kind of a
Gatling gun of ideas.
We have a great set of speakers
today to kind of
round out the second day of I/O.
And believe you me, these
people will enlighten you.
And what these--
in case you haven't been to an
Ignite before, what we have
here is a series of five minute
presentations, where
each speaker gets just five
minutes on stage.
They get 20 slides.
They get 15 seconds a slide.
And just like me, they have no
control over those slides.
And so it makes it for a little
bit more frenetic--
a little more fun if they're
drunk-- which they're not.
We didn't bring whiskey--
but it has its charms anyway.
And we've got a great selection
of content tonight.
Now Ignite, if you haven't heard
of it before, is in over
200 cities around the world.
So I encourage you to go home
and participate in your local
one or start one.
Now our 13 speakers are going to
cover topics as diverse as
the Shenzhen hardware ecosystem,
the Marvel data--
Marvel Comics, that is,
and the rise K-Pop.
Now, a good friend of mine who
actually spoke at the very
first Ignite, is here
to talk about better
living through Bluetooth.
Please welcome Dan Shapiro.
DAN SHAPIRO: Thank you Brady.
So I got this amazing
headband.
You put it on.
It has these little silver
eye sensors.
It measures the microvolt
signals coming off of your
brain and the twitch from your
eye muscles, sends to your
phone via Bluetooth, where
there's a neural network that
decodes them and puts
them up in a graph.
It's called a Zeo.
And it basically knows if you're
sleeping, it knows if
you're awake--
It's like Santa Claus
in a box.
It can tell you your
sleep over the
course of a whole night.
I got this for my dad.
He wanted to learn more about
his sleep habits.
Unfortunately, what he learned
about his sleep is that he's
in the habit of grabbing the
thing off his head in the
middle of the night and throwing
it against the wall
very vigorously.
So he never got too
much from it.
But I thought it was amazing.
I actually have trouble falling
asleep-- always have.
And so I wound up getting all
this data every morning.
I could tell what the phases
of sleep were, if I
woke up, how long--
and what I learned was, I always
thought it took me an
hour to fall asleep.
It actually only took me half
an hour to fall asleep.
And this was magical.
Because once I knew it, I
started falling asleep in 15
minutes because I wasn't
stressed out anymore.
And once I started falling
asleep in 15 minutes I started
going to bed earlier, because
hey, I didn't, like, postpone
it because I thought I was going
be tossing and turning.
It was awesome.
So just by getting the data,
I wound up sleeping better.
And as the nights wore on I
wound up having more REM
sleep, more deep sleep, and
longer nights of sleep, even
though I wasn't doing any,
like, bedtime setting
craziness-- nothing like that.
I was just following the data.
So more data.
I went to my doctor and I said
I want to get a sleep study.
This is where they strap 20
electrodes on your skull.
They measure your arm motion,
your leg motion, your
respirometry--
the whole thing.
And it turns out I have
something called sleep apnea,
which basically means I
stop breathing in the
middle of the night.
So I get this sweet jet fighter
mask that I get to
wear every evening that prevents
the heart damage that
comes from sleep apnea,
and actually
helps me sleep better.
I was talking about this with my
friend Matt, who also had a
sleep study, and he said, you
know, my sponsor for my latest
video is this company up in
the corner called 23andMe.
You should send them
a cup of your spit.
Because these guys actually
measure your chromosomes, and
tell you all sorts of
interesting stuff about yourself.
So I drooled into a little cup,
shipped it off to them,
and it was amazing.
I learned I'm predisposed
to heroin addiction.
I learned I'm a descendant
from the
Cohen tribe of Israel.
I learned that I'm at seriously
elevated risk of dandruff--
3 and 1/2 times the normal
person's risk.
But the thing that was most
interesting was I learned I'm
a fast caffeine metabolizer.
Now, I've never been a
coffee drinker, which
is kind of a shame.
Because coffee is like vitamin
C. The more research that's
done, the longer the list of
things that coffee seems to
prove to prevent--
Alzheimer's, Parkinson's,
cavities for Pete's sake.
This stuff is miraculous.
One problem.
Coffee tends to lead
to heart attacks.
But not for fast caffeine
metabolizers.
Fast caffeine metabolizers who
drink coffee regularly in
moderation actually experience
fewer heart attacks than the
general population.
Sweet.
So now I'm drinking
coffee every day.
That was easy.
At work they offered to give
us this health workup.
They give you a yellow, red,
or green for all sorts of
different attributes.
I did it and I don't
eat particularly--
I eat a lot and I don't like to
exercise, so I thought it
was going bad.
They basically came back and
said, Dan, you should lose
some weight.
OK, wait.
This isn't like LDL
cholesterol.
This is physics.
This is mass.
I can measure this.
So I bought a Bluetooth scale.
Every morning I stand on
the Bluetooth scale.
It sends the weight
to my phone--
to the web--
and the weirdest thing
happened--
data.
Change started happening.
I started losing weight.
I didn't go on a fancy diet.
A friend of mine at work started
going vegan at the
same time, and he dropped
weight a lot
faster than I did.
But the man was miserable.
I was losing weight just by
watching what was going on.
OK.
Well wait.
Let's try exercise.
I've never held an exercise
regime in my life but this
little thing, this Bluetooth
pedometer cost $50.
I've got one in my pocket,
gave a half dozen to my
friends and coworkers, and
I've gone from walking an
average of about 2,500 steps a
day to 8,500 steps a day just
by watching the email that
comes out every week that
makes fun of me for not walking
enough when my friends
are doing more than I am.
So, I'm sleeping better.
I'm eating better.
I'm drinking more coffee, which
I've learned is a good
thing, and I've lost weight.
I am not a health guru.
I am no fitness expert.
I am not going to tell you
how to live your life.
But there is something I
want to suggest to you.
If there is some aspect of your
life that you would like
to change, you could do a lot
worse than finding some gadget
that can measure it for you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER OLSON: Hi.
As I wait for the slides.
My name's Peter Olson.
I work for Marvel
Entertainment.
Some of you may have heard
of this company.
And I'm going to talk to you
today about the challenges of
finding structure and meaning
in very complicated data
sets-- say a data set that has
been put together by hundreds
of writers, artists, editors
over the course of 70 years.
Now, a lot of you probably deal
with very important real
world data sets, and I'm hoping
that our exploration
into fictional data sets
is of some use to you.
Now comic universes are
amazing places.
People can fly.
They can survive lethal
doses of radiation.
Southern accents sound
like that.
But they do not lend themselves
to structure.
But in order to represent
a universe and the
bibliographical things that
contain it, you need
structure, you need data, you
need schemas, you need
semantics, you need data types,
and you need a shared
understanding of how entities
behave in the universe you're
looking at.
And I believe personally that
data is actually part of the
comic's experience.
If you've ever been in an
argument over whether
Wolverine could beat Sabertooth,
or Batman could
beat Superman--
and I've bet a lot
of you have--
you've been in an argument
about data.
Data also gives us new
and interesting ways
at looking at fiction.
This is a graph representation
of the Marvel Universe.
Each point is a character.
Each line is an interaction
between one or more
characters.
So a first challenge--
how do you
represent a fictional entity?
Now you might think it's a
pretty simple exercise.
There's an entity.
It has attributes.
Those attributes are
relatively static.
So you think of Hawkeye.
He has blond hair.
He is an archer.
He has a purple costume.
He shoots arrows.
And we modeled characters like
this for a long time.
And then we started to look at
the stories, and we realized
that this wasn't a complete look
at how characters behave
in fiction.
The important thing about
fiction, and characters in
them, is that they change.
So Hawkeye has been a villain.
He was Goliath.
He was Hawkeye.
He was dead.
He was Ronin.
He came back.
And now he's Hawkeye just
in time for the movie.
Another challenge--
comics use bibliographical
organization to tell stories.
So you might think, OK
I've have seen the
Captain America movie.
I want to read the first issue
of Captain America.
Where should I start?
Oh, Captain America,
number one.
Well there are six Captain
America number ones.
This isn't just Marvel.
DC just renumbered their entire
line about a year ago.
And renumbering is actually
a way of signaling to an
audience that something
important has happened in this
story, in this character.
It's actually part of the
comic's experience.
By the way, if you actually want
to find Captain's first
appearance, it's not in a book
called Captain America.
It's Captain America Comics.
Yes that is Cap punching
Hitler in the face.
The first book called Captain
America starts with issue 100.
This type of thing happens
all the time in comics.
X Men becomes New X Men becomes
X Men and then goes
back to X Men--
goes to X Men Legacy without
changing numbering.
The Incredible Hulk dropped its
main character but kept
its numbering.
The Deadpool book starts at
900 and counts backwards.
Oftentimes bibliographical
structures fight against story
experience.
If you think of stories as an
ordered sequence of events--
they have a beginning,
they have a middle,
they have an end--
you would expect that the books
that organize those
stories follow that
story in sequence.
So in the Spiderman books, you
would expect that a story
flows from friendly neighborhood
Spider Man, to
one, to two, to three,
to four, and so on.
But in order to read this
story-- it's call Spiderman,
The Other-- you actually have
to read across series.
This is very, very difficult
to represent to consumers--
to people who have never read
a comic book before.
So what can you do when you
have crazy data like this?
Well first, find atoms.
Find things that are
indivisible--
that don't change.
And often these atoms
are under the hood.
They're not in the entity you're
used to dealing with.
So in the example of characters,
we found the thing
that is important is not a given
set of entity attributes
that doesn't change.
It's that there are moments in
story time where entities have
specific attributes.
For comics we found that there
are indivisible units of story
that exist outside of the
bibliographical structures.
And those units of stories can
be organized into new and
interesting organizational
entities such as storylines,
such as character timelines,
and things like that.
So thanks.
If you're interested in this
type of comic arcana, we have
a schema.org proposal currently
under consideration.
And you can get me
@dethtron5000.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
FREDDY VEGA: My name
is Freddy Vega.
I came from the exotic land
of South America--
Colombia.
And I'm here to talk about how
we are living in the best age
of humanity ever, and that's
thanks to education--
mainly online education.
There's a lot of people talking
about online education.
Coursera is incredible.
EdX is amazing.
There's something called Massive
Online Open Courses.
It's like a MMORPG's, but
without the multi-player part.
They are doing great things,
but online education can be
so, so much more.
This is a story that
starts in 2004.
I wanted to learn PHP.
There was such an era
when PHP was cool.
And so I went ahead and used
PHP to create Cristalab--
a community of web designers
and developers.
That community grew a lot.
We are right now at
two million unique
visitors per month.
So we decided to create
another company.
So with Christian Van Der Henst,
that guy over there, we
created Mejorando la.
Mejorando la is a company
dedicated to organize courses
around Spain and
Latin America--
courses about HTML5,
Node js, Python.
We started in 2010, and we've
already done 30 courses around
12 countries.
And we teach to 3,000 students
all of these technologies--
HTML5, Python, Node js.
We wanted to bring them the
best, not just the PHP course.
I'm sorry about all
the PHP lovers.
I'm so, so sorry.
These courses are great.
And they started to grow
incredibly, incredibly popular
because we were doing
something different.
For example I think that copying
from the projector, or
from a white board
is medieval.
So we have a central server
and other things to copy.
But traveling sucks.
Traveling plus 9/11
absolutely sucks.
And we were traveling to a
different country each week.
I was tired of travel, and I
wanted to fix online education
with a multi-player part.
So what's wrong with that
Massive Online Open Course
that we have right now?
Right now Massive Online Open
Courses are specialized CMS
for text and media.
And sadly nothing more.
They are doing a great job for
bringing the best content on
big, huge brand schools to
all people for free.
But they are lacking the
connection to students.
Coursera right now has a
retention rate of 7%.
EdX and Udacity have
similar numbers.
That means that for each 100
people that try to take a
course on Coursera, only
seven people finish.
Why is that happening?
So we tried to create a
different kind of system--
a different kind of education
system that will fix that.
And we were trying to gather
inspiration from where people
were really spending time.
So I tried to earn inspiration
from threaded discussions,
quota questions, gaming
and streaming--
a lot of people are spending
time over there-- and we
created something
called Platzi.
Platzi is online education
with that part.
We tried to bring
that community
part to online education.
We didn't have any money because
funding in Latin
America is almost nonexistent,
but we did
these on-site courses.
We used all the money from
the on-site courses
to create the platform.
This is the platform.
And it has all the things that
you would normally expect from
a platform.
It has guides, text,
media tutorials,
and blah, blah, blah.
But interesting things are
on the right side.
That's our question
and answer system.
A question in our system is
only as big as a tweet.
People have to be specific
to ask questions.
You have nested comments,
very similar to a
mobile version of Reddit.
You have upboats, downboats.
We also have a system where
people can write answers with
Read Text and code without
needing to
run Markdown or BBCode.
Just [INAUDIBLE], as far as
I know, is the only one.
Our first course generated
40,000 questions.
And 99.1% were rightfully
answered, mostly by the
students, because we were
making the best
students answer it.
And the slow or normal students
are being leveled out
by those best students.
We also have live streaming
classes.
We are using a technology that
enables us to do online
streaming in PCs, desktops,
mobiles, et cetera.
When a teacher wants to share
a file, he just right-hand
drops, and the students
see it on the corner.
And if it can be selectable,
its colored, et cetera--
also for any kind of file.
Chats are normally useless.
But in our system, the students
use the chat as an
annotation system and it has
the stars, an about.
So the system outergenerates
a summary of each class
automatically, after one
of each classes.
In three courses, 97% of the
students finish everything.
We've done three
courses so far.
So it works.
Our system works.
How much have we done this?
How many students
have we reached?
We've done three courses
this year.
We had 3,400 students, charging
$95 to each of them.
And right now we have only
done this in Spanish.
We are really wondering what
happens if we do this in the
English world.
What I want to say is that
online education is not about
technology.
It's not even around who's
teaching or who's certifying.
It's about finding a way to
connect the students to our
students, to create the
workshops, the study groups,
and the things that
the students
normally do in colleges.
And if you want to learn more,
if you want to know more about
the platform, or you want to
say, hey you are wrong,
education is like this and like
that, please contact me
over there on Twitter.
Thank you
very, very much [APPLAUSE]
NATHAN FREITAS: So I was
encouraged yesterday at the
keynote, hearing about Android
and the reach of Google
wanting to expand to the rest
of the world that we haven't
gotten to yet with
this technology.
Unfortunately, the rest of the
world doesn't always work the
way we think it should, and
doesn't treat users with the
same respect that we
think they should.
The great firewall might be a
familiar term to a lot of you
but the problem today is more
one of a panopticon--
an all-seeing eye at the end of
a gun, where every action a
user is doing is being
surveilled.
We're not talking about
blocking a site.
We're talking about all the
activities of a user in their
mobile device and their
digital life.
And the surveillance
is crowdsourced.
It's not just one firewall.
It's every person around you.
The onus is on the company,
the service provider, the
software creator to observe
and watch and report and
filter to create a harmonious
society.
It's not about websites
anymore.
It's about ebooks and apps--
filtering them, blocking them,
reporting their authors.
It's about blocking artists
and cultural figures from
communicating such as Ai
Weiwei's Gangnam Style video,
which never reached a mass
audience in China.
So into this comes an
app like WeChat.
WeChat is yet another of these
all-messaging, all-phone, take
all your communications and
put it through our app--
all with stickers and emoji,
and colorful icons, and a
whole lot of fun and
great marketing.
So WeChat is a Chinese
company.
This is what's interesting.
It's been growing like
crazy since 2012.
It's got numbers, WhatsApp
numbers, Facebook numbers,
Twitter numbers-- it has HangOut
numbers in and it
didn't even auto-install
the app.
So it's really crazy.
So you take this issue that it's
a Chinese company working
within a Chinese society, and
of course you have baggage
like restricted keywords
happening, right?
So keywords being filtered--
Tibet, Taiwan, Tiananmen
obviously, but much more.
Eviction, environment,
everything--
and now that's exported
to the world.
So what we've seen is that
Hu Jia, a famous Chinese
activist, decided, well maybe
I can use this WeChat to
organize and communicate.
And what he found was
the opposite.
It had made the surveillance
state that much more
efficient, within an hour, able
to report and communicate
and interrogate.
Expand this to others
in China--
Tibetans who have been fighting
a battle to have
their country back for
over 50 years.
They gravitate towards
smartphones because it helps
them communicate to
their exile and
diaspora family members.
At the same time as the rise of
WeChat, we've seen a rise
in the self-immolation protest,
where Tibetans are
setting themselves on fire
in order to have
their voices heard.
So of course this is a topic
of discussion for Tibetans
around the world.
They're using WeChat.
Of course they are.
It's the best way to
get information
when it's not filtered.
And so inevitably we see Tibetan
monks being arrested
for using WeChat to talk about
things that are happening
right around them
with each other.
Instead of texting or calling,
they're using this friendly
auto-surveillance state app.
Now there is a light at the
end of this tunnel.
There's something that Tibetans
are doing themselves.
A project called the YakChat,
based on code by
[? Marley Moxenspike, ?]
that uses secure messaging along
with delightful icons to
create a humorous response to
such a bad, onerous problem.
So YakChat is an app that is
available for Android.
It's open source.
But it's not really about WeChat
or China or Tibetans.
This is really about you.
Because the problems in China
are quickly becoming problems
everywhere.
The tools are being
commoditized.
The software is easy.
Everyone knows how to do
surveillance state stuff.
So you really need to encrypt
all the things, right?
Because you don't know who might
be doing something that
someone doesn't like.
You could be gay in Uganda, you
could be a woman in Saudi
Arabia, you could be a
journalist just about
anywhere, these days.
You can't expect the network
to behave properly.
Man in the middle attacks
are normal.
CA cert route, pwnage, and
exploits are normal.
You need to use things like Tor,
and build proxying into
your applications.
Twitter added proxy support
into Twitter.
Why does your app not
have proxy support?
You need to expect the internet
may not exist.
And if you've been at this
conference, you can sympathize
with that because every single
app just falls over and stops
working as soon as there's
no internet, right?
So you need to build in
peer-to-peer, mesh.
And finally--
well not finally, there's
a few more slides--
free beer is good.
Free stuff is great, especially
for activists and
people around the world.
But you need to consider the
impact on speech, and the
ability for them to express
themselves and to build on
your code, and to build
on what you've done.
So YakChat came out of
TextSecure which is an open
source project from Moxie.
To stop being serious for a
moment, emoji are awesome.
Emoticons, stickers, emoji--
I love these things.
People that work in movements
that work for change are often
very creative and expressive.
So you can't make an
app that's boring.
Ultimately, China is an amazing
culture and it's an
amazing place.
And I want them to take their
place in this world.
And I love cultures
within China.
There's so much-- the
Tibetan culture--
you can learn more
about China.
The reason WeChat is taking off
is they know more about us
than we know about them.
So you need to take
responsibility and make your
apps great.
And use some of this code
we have at Guardian
Project to do that.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
KIM TECK CHUA: Hello everyone.
I'm Kim from Singapore.
So as you can see from the slide
show, this is the Helix
Bridge we have in Singapore.
And the reason why it's being
named Helix Bridge is because
it's part of the
DNA structure.
And it also represents life.
So the topic I'm talking about
today is digital afterlife.
So, in the 18th and 19th
century, when a user actually
passes away, how do they
actually announce it to the
family members and the
rest of the people?
They do it through
word of mouth.
So what they would do
is that, you tell--
OK.
You get how many of the
gold, how many of the
house, and so on.
And fast moving forward into
the 1960's and through the
1990's, people actually
started using a will.
And they would write down in a
will how much of this that you
will actually get.
And moving forward to 2000, we
are still living in a written
will concept, where we
don't have a concept
of the digital world.
So when a user has passed on,
let's say in social media and
stuff, the account is actually
left vacant.
So we can see that in social
network, we have more than one
billion mildly active users.
And this is has actually created
a very huge potential.
And you can also see that, as
more and more users get
online, we actually have
more online friends
than offline friends.
So this a page of Larry Page.
And I got it from my Google+.
We have a lot of information
overload where information
comes from all around the
world, all around the
different content, like multiple
devices, like, in the
day we use the iPhone or we
use the Google Android.
And at night, we
use the tablet.
So we also face, more and more,
older generations coming
into the online world.
So we have seen the younger
generation has actually
populated the social
media online.
And from this graph you can
actually see that the fastest
growth now is actually coming
from the older generation.
So the question lies within
what happens if the user
actually passes on to the world,
and who will actually
take care of all that
digital excess, like
on the social network.
Or if suddenly you find one
day, this person no longer
updates the posts on Facebook
or Google+.
As far as the email, we have
seen more and more of us are
storing a lot of valuable
information in emails.
What happens to the email
accounts if no one is
accessing it?
And we can really see from
financial accounts, like the
stock market, 4x, and the rest
where we put in a lot of
investment in it--
a lot of finance and wealth.
And what happens if one fine
day, we do not have--
nobody is aware of what the user
has actually put in into
the online accounts.
And also digital access like
Google drive, Cloud,
Dropbox, and so on.
So we create a lot of content
every day, and this is
constantly uploaded to
the online storage.
And also the online
subscriptions, like movies,
gaming accounts, and so on.
So more and more information
is being uploaded and
subsequently, everyone is
concerned about creating more
information.
But this also creates a term
called the digital black hole,
where data is being left
vacant on the server.
So for all the developers out
there, you can see that
digital actually grows.
And all you need is more storage
on the internet.
But there will be a problem
where you will see, what
happens to the inactive data
storage out there.
It will increase on its own.
And nobody is aware of why it's
happening over there.
So this is a pretty
big problem--
And of course, missing person
in action, where we have our
friends, and our online friends,
where you won't be
actually aware of what happens
to each of them until we
actually find out from the
physical connections.
So recently Google actually
launched the Google inactive
account manager, where it allows
the user to set a time
time-out period where you will
ping the user, after the user
doesn't log in after
a certain time.
So this is wise as the first
step in making the data
management more efficient.
And of course we will
subsequently see more and more
relevant services coming
out in the market.
And the last slide
which I want to
share is unspoken words.
So I'm sure that many of us have
many words which we may
not say to each and every
one of them at certain
times of your life.
So this is one [INAUDIBLE]
of vSwitch I
would like to highlight.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOYCE KIM: Hi everybody.
I'm Joyce Kim and I'm here to
talk to you about Korean pop.
So quick quiz-- how many of
these guys do you recognize?
On one side we have Kim Jung
Un, the Supreme leader of
North Korea.
In the middle we have Psy,
the Korean pop sensation.
And the last guy?
That's just my baby brother.
I threw him in there because he
looks like the other guys.
So Korea is awesome.
Korea has actually been
impacting pop culture on the
web for quite some time now.
And I'm here to give you a crash
course on the industry
that brought you
Gangnam Style.
So Korean pop got its start in
1992, when a band call Seo
Taiji Boys debuted on the Korean
equivalent to American
Idol on TV.
They were unlike anything
Korea had ever seen.
They had electronic music
mixed with hip hop.
They had these choreographed
b-boy moves, and the judges
absolutely hated them.
They came in dead last.
But the very next day, their
sales started to go through
the roof, and they quickly
became the longest running
number one hit in
Korean history.
After that we had a flurry
of girl bands and
boy bands come up.
They look kind of silly to
us right now, right?
We're not used to seeing
groups like this.
Really?
If we look at the '90s here in
the US, it actually wasn't
that different.
We had the Spice Girls.
We had New Kids on the Block.
We had the Backstreet Boys.
So the reality is that pop
music is really about
manufactured groups.
And if we go back a little bit
further in history we can end
up in the Motown era.
So Motown came about at a time
when TV distribution was new.
And for the first time, people
really start to care about
what the singers looked like.
So I want you start thinking
about Korean pop as the next
iteration of the Motown model,
only for the internet era.
So let's talk about
the people.
Korean pop stars, like their
Motown predecessors, tend to
be ridiculously good looking.
And it's not like they went to a
school of really hot people,
and then decided to make
music together.
They are assembled this way.
They are brought together
through a series of intensive
auditions and scouting that
happens all across the world.
And because Korean pop always
had its eye on international
growth, they really recruit
talent that
speaks foreign languages.
So these two singers, who are
really popular in Korea, are
not even Korean.
He's Thai-American and she's a
Chinese-American rapper from
L.A. But both of them speak
Korean fluently.
So the reason they speak Korean
fluently is because
most Korean pop stars are put
through a very intensive,
full-time, two to seven year
training program, from
audition to debut, where they're
trained in everything,
from singing and dancing,
and of course,
more foreign languages.
So you're probably asking, why
they always so focused in
foreign languages.
Well it's because the fact that
people outside of Korea
don't speak Korean.
So how do they deal with
this challenge?
Anybody that's worked with
content on the web knows that
internationalization is a really
hard nut to crack.
So how did Korea take
this issue on?
It comes down to one fact.
Korea is really wired.
We have fastest internet
in the world.
People are always connected.
And what this culture of
connectedness has created is a
nation full of online marketing
experts, from
StarCraft to Psy.
Koreans just really know
how to use the web.
So Korean music executives--
they kind of looked
at the situation.
They said, you know what, we
think we can use the internet
to get more fans.
But how do you really start to
communicate with fans that
don't speak the same
language as you?
One option is photos.
And Twitter became a great way
of posting photos online to
talk to fans that didn't speak
the same language as you.
Do guys know who this cat is?
This cat is more famous
than all of us in
this room put together.
He's owned by a Korean pop
star named Hee Chul.
And this cat spent most of his
2011 hanging out on the global
Twitter trending list alongside
Justin Bieber.
And the reason that is, is that
Hee Chul would tweet a
photo of his cat, and then the
internet would just explode,
because we know that the
internet is powered by cats,
so it had that impact.
So from here they
went to YouTube.
YouTube was used really
differently.
Because they wanted
international sales, they
started to change the songs
and add really catchy
repetitive English lyrics,
for better or for worse.
And the subtitled versions
would end up on YouTube.
And this allowed non-Korean
fans to sing along to the
songs that they loved.
The other thing they did is they
invested really heavily
in the music videos.
Korean music videos are epic.
They're insane.
They are designed to tell a
story to somebody who doesn't
speak the language.
You can see that Gangnam
Style is kind of the
epitome of that trend.
So where does Psy fit
into all of this?
It's kind of interesting to
note, in Korea, Psy is
represented by an agency called
YG Entertainment, one
of the top three record
labels in Korea.
YG was founded by the same
singer whose own debut was
ridiculed by the
judges in 1992.
So Psy is repped by the
godfather of Korean pop.
Now this guy pretty much hacked
television distribution
in Korea in 1992 by becoming
a breakout success.
In the past few years, he's
been focused on internet
distribution and figuring
out how to make
that work for K-Pop.
So it's no accident that Gangnam
Style became a success
on YouTube, because this man
had spent years focused on
internet distribution.
So what did you guys
know about Korea
before you came in?
You knew that we make
great phones that
most of you guys have.
You know that we kick ass in
StarCraft But now you know
that we can dance, and that
it's a nation full of user
acquisition experts.
So hopefully in the past few
minutes,I've piqued your
curiosity a little bit
about Korean pop.
If you want to learn more, I
made a playlist on YouTube.
So you can go to that bit.ly
link, slash kpop101 to see
some of my favorites and some
historic K-Pop videos.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
JOYCE KIM: So they're going to
be switching the slide deck.
And they wanted to
take a picture of
everybody in the meantime.
So everybody get up and do
your best horsey dance.
Or at least put your hands up
in the air and smile so this
gentleman can take a
photo of everybody.
Hi everyone!
All right great.
Oh, one more for him.
Thanks, everyone.
PANOS PAPADOPOULOS: Thank
you very much.
Unfortunately, my presentation
has no beautiful girls.
It's mostly about crisis
and money lost.
So, you know, I'm from Greece,
so I'm the right person to
talk about the StartApps and
how to save Greece-- not.
So I'm Panos Papadopoulos.
I'm the founder of Bugsense.
It's one of the most used
Android SDKs in the world,
actually after Google
and [INAUDIBLE].
And we started during
a time of crisis.
And a crisis is not something
that you're going to react.
It's something you
have to plan.
Because there is this function,
The Kondratieff Wave.
And he was an economist in the
Soviet Union, and he found out
that capitalists have
these cycles, so it
distracts and recreates.
And then he found out that the
capitalism is more stable, so
they sent him to Siberia.
So I was in Greece, when I was
a student, and there was the
Olympic Games.
We were in the Euro.
Everything was great.
And everybody wanted to be
working in the public sector,
and be a teacher
for 400 years--
for 2000.
But then they said I have
to invest in knowledge.
And you know, here
we're close.
And we're in the news every day,
which is awesome, because
we have all the TV studios in
the world in Syntagma Square--
the Doctor Who-- we
have everyone.
If you want to be famous,
come to Greece.
So then there was-- every day
you listen to the news.
On Monday, the banks
are closed.
So I was betting here.
I was staying in a motel in
Mountain View, dirty.
And then I was listening to the
mandate there would be no
ATM to get money.
So you can imagine that's a
great time to have a StartApp
and you have great psychology.
Of course it's not.
But what can you do?
This is life.
Bad things happen, and the only
thing we can do is burn
the ships and go forward.
That's what the Athenians
did when they were
attacked by the Persians.
So what we do?
You know, we're developers.
You can find a job everywhere.
But we wanted to have
our own business.
And so this advertisement in
the airport, for HSBC.
Every company is going
to be multinational.
So you can be [INAUDIBLE]
at selling souvenirs to
tourists, but you have to
speak, like, ten languages.
You can even make shoes.
You can sell them online.
And of course there's
this StartApp
movement, which is global.
And you can make a business--
a thriving
business in a weekend--
of course not.
But everybody in the world can
create something online and
put it and make money.
Of course you knew
that already.
So it's very easy to
do that these days.
Everything is flat.
You have great services, like
Google App Engine, and
Twitter, Reddits to promote.
We started with Agility Group
to find the first market.
We hosted the Google App
Engine to be scalable.
We built an Android with the
fastest growing platform.
And of course we found
code to keep up the
with the first iteration.
We're didn't start
from the scratch.
Challenge accepted, yes.
Now we're a StartApp.
We're famous.
We're going to be
at Tech Runs.
We'll be there at [INAUDIBLE].
And this is how you're going to
make money after we raise
like a few million funds.
Of course this is not the
way it is when you're in
a country in crisis.
So you go back to the basics.
What I'm going to do here--
actually it's about jobs.
I want a job for me,
first of all.
But a StartApp is not
freelancing, so you have to
find other people.
And you have to respect the
fact that, in crisis, they
feel insecure.
So they need a job.
They need a job that
they can relate to.
It can be interesting.
You don't want them to go to
another country, because it's
technology, and it's
very challenging.
So you have to have a mission.
And the mission is
self-improvement--
self-improvement, personal
growth, and of course, have a
nice payday at the
end of the month.
And this is what keeps
you going.
Because you don't make money all
the time, but you have to
have a mission when you're
in a crisis.
So you're in a crisis.
You are the center
of the world.
But basically you're
not in the network.
You're not in the network that
matters, which is the Silicon
Valley, or whatever you do
according to your business.
So if you're a great developer,
you have money.
But if you're not
a center in the
network, this is a problem.
And of course revenue matters.
Cash flow is king.
Your competitors have
a lot of money.
But you're in crisis.
So the only thing you can
do is look at this--
your cash flow.
So yes it's ten Euro cents,
or ten drachmas.
The next day it's twenty
drachmas-- it's double--
still drachma though.
So you are the whole StartApp.
And this is the good thing.
Journalists, they
like the story.
You have two guys from Greece.
They have to battle
with this crisis.
So go on, and tell the story.
So people love the stories.
And you are on the news.
And because you're on the news,
you can attract talent.
You can attract talent
through stories.
And of course you have
to be a Spartan.
Actually, I am.
You have to battle, not only
because you have to prove
yourself to us, because you
are from nowhere, but also
because of your competitors--
you have the perception about
yourself that you are a
lesser, because you don't have
the basic capital, or you're
on no Tech Runs.
And you have to fight.
And then, you know, everything
is systemic.
You cannot be on your own
and make something.
You have also to create
the ecosystem in your
city or your country.
We do it in Greece, people do it
in Barcelona with Barcelona
I/O. So it's not
about yourself.
It's about the ecosystem
of where you are.
And then after you have the
velocity speed, think big.
No, you're not allowed, because
there's more StartApp
in the crisis.
You can do things better.
So your competitors
are big in the US.
So what?
Go away.
Go to Japan.
Go to Korea.
You go to China.
There are opportunities
everywhere.
It's just about the
perception.
Don't think you are miserable
because you're in a country
hit by crisis.
And of course there is slack.
If you are a villager back in
15th-century Europe, you will
be a villager for the
rest of your life.
There's no way to be
a cleric or a king.
So the US revolution told us,
you can't be everywhere.
You can try, but there
is only lack.
So don't blame yourself
all the time.
It's also a matter of flack
if you don't make it.
Crisis.
That's a varied stereotype, but
crisis is an opportunity.
So plan for the next crisis and
said opportunity is there.
[APPLAUSE]
MARCO COCHRANE: Hello.
So I did "Bliss Dance" for
Burning Man in 2010.
At the time I had never done
anything that big or built
anything in that way.
And the way I did it was to
follow my bliss, and let doors
open where I didn't know
doors existed.
I'm really interested
in patterns and
structure in the universe.
And I used to dream
this every night--
triangles and triangles and
triangles and triangles.
I got into patterns that exist
in the universe that are
repetitive.
And one of them is an attractor
that's surrounded by
material and energy.
If you use that as a model, it's
a little scary because
there are no straight lines.
It's all spirals.
So you have to trust that what
you need is going to come when
you need it.
So in the center of this project
was a sculpture that I
did in 2006.
OK.
And I did it with Deja
Solis, the model.
And there's something--
one of my favorite pieces.
So what I needed to do was
enlarge it to 15 feet.
And I had never done anything
that big before, so I used a
panograph, which is in the
background there--
a tool from 1602--
very low tech.
That's the armature
for the clay.
And I put clay all over it.
And it ended up pretty good.
There it is.
That was the biggest sculpture I
had ever done at that point.
So the next thing was to draw a
pattern on that clay piece.
And that was actually a lot of
work to figure out how to make
all the lines flow together,
and build a mold.
So that's-- you can see
the lines drawn
on it and the mold.
So I needed the mold so I could
make a hard copy, so I
could use the panograph again
to build basically a giant
point cloud, that could hold
itself up, and deal with high
winds and reality.
So one of the problems with that
is how do I hang these
balls in three dimensional
space, that I would then
connect to.
So I had to invent this little
tool here that's made out of
goose necks and magnets to hold
the balls in 3D reality
and weld to them.
There's 55,000 connections
and I couldn't
possibly do that myself.
So one of the flow things that
happened is people came into
my life that I didn't even know,
who spent six months at
a time for free to help
me build this thing.
And many other people
helped too.
One of the other aspects that
was really important to me was
the beauty of the
piece itself.
And the structure was much more
beautiful than I thought
it would be in my mind.
And that was really fun--
fun to play in and
fun to climb on.
One of the things that
I hadn't even
thought of was the color--
the lighting system.
I hadn't dealt with
RGB LEDs before.
And somebody put one inside of
that structure and it just
made it come to life.
And it became a big aspect
of the sculpture itself.
Risk-taking--
the face on something--
on a sculpture is really
important.
In doing this wire
frame, I had to--
I just hoped that when I put
mesh on it, it would actually
work and be a beautiful face.
And it did.
I was really happy with it.
So that year was total success
and wonderful.
And the flow happened.
So in 2011, I brought the next
piece, which is "Truth is
Beauty." This is the
torso of it.
And I wanted people to be able
to climb in it and hang out in
this, structure like we had
done when we built it.
So this year we're bringing the
finished product, which
will be 55 feet tall.
That's the clay version of it
to Burning Man this year, so
if any of you are going,
it will be there.
I always like to think big
to keep myself motivated.
So before I die, I hope
that this happens--
200 foot "Bliss Dance"
on Alcatraz.
That's the Statue of Freedom
on a prison.
You've got to go for that.
So truth is beauty.
Your truth is your bliss.
And if you find that within
yourself, and follow it, doors
will open where you didn't
know they existed.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHARLIE DECK: OK I'm going to
shift into a different kind of
beauty here because I'm about to
share something spectacular
and surprising about numbers.
And it all starts with a doodle
in 1964, at UC San
Diego where this man, Stanislaw
Ulam, the legendary
mathematician who helped
invent the computer and
discover nuclear fission, is
stuck in a department meeting.
And he's bored.
But he's a mathematician,
so when he's
bored he doodles numbers.
One, two, three-- the numbers
are marching out in a spiral.
And in his boredom he decides
to see what happens when he
circles the prime numbers.
And when he does something very
special does indeed happen.
The prime numbers tend to line
up along these diagonals.
And that defies our intuition
that prime numbers are hard to
calculate or are distributed in
a randomish way along the
number line.
And it turns out that there is
something to these spirals
with respect to primes.
And they're called Ulam Spirals
after this man.
When I found out about them
I couldn't wait to
start making my own.
So I started my own doodle,
but this time in code.
And I'm going to share some
of my explorations.
I started simply though, just
with the number line--
One, two, three, four,
in order left to
right, top to bottom.
The bright squares are primes
and the dark squares are
everything else.
Now I taught my doodle how to
go into the Ulam Spiral.
And as you can see, we are way
more zoomed out than we were a
second ago.
But you can see just how
consistent the pattern of
primes is along those diagonals,
but also how
inconsistent it is.
Is this just a coincidence
in the noise?
Well let's compare it to a
grid where I've lit up
completely random numbers.
And I think that will convince
you that there really is
something special
going on here.
But what's really exciting is
it's not just this square
spiral I constructed triangular
spirals, hexagonal
spirals, circular spirals, and
in each one we see some kind
of recognizable, and conspicuous
order going on
with respect to the
primes-- they're
these little diagonals.
So what's going on?
We're curling numbers in a
spiral, and for some reason
the prime numbers seem
to be lining
up along these diagonals.
Well I went online, I found
some code that fits three
points to a quadratic equation,
plugged that into
the doodle, and I went and
saw what would happen.
And it was incredible.
It turns out that these
diagonals line up perfectly
along just that kind
of equation.
I could select a given arm in
the prime-- in the number
spiral, I mean.
And that meant I could address
the question of whether we're
seeing the same order across
these different spirals.
Is the prime-rich vein in one
spiral the same as the
prime-rich vein in another?
Well in my doodle, I had all the
features already there, so
I could see for myself.
This is just a tiny selection
of all the different
possibilities I could have shown
you, but I think you can
see that there is a relationship
there.
But it's complex.
And it's varied.
And this-- you know, from here
I could construct more
complicated arrangements of
numbers, or maybe we could
look at semi-primes or
perfect numbers.
But there's even more beauty
if we go simpler.
And what's simpler than
prime numbers
is just simple multiples.
And these are the same number
spirals, but I'm just
highlighting 22, 44, 66, 88--
multiples along those spirals.
And if I animate the multiple
that I'm highlighting, you get
a whole secondary
pattern that--
like a perceptual phenomenon
that emerges from the
underlying patterns.
And again, I mean I cut this
talk in half, and half again.
There's so much more I could
share with you, but I want to
leave you with two big
picture points.
And one is about the process,
that my doodle was just as
casual as the original doodle
in that department meeting.
It's just the product of some
procrastination, a little bit
of creative coding, and I got
to experience the thrill of
exploring some of these
ideas for myself.
That can and that should be one
of the joys of having some
coding skills.
Our skills are like a prosthesis
or an amplifier for
imagination.
And that's not just an
empty platitude.
The second point is about why
it's important to look at
something so abstract
this way.
In the platonic sense,
these patterns
have always been here.
They always will be here.
It's like the sound of a tree
falling in the woods, but it's
always there whenever we
bother to tune into it.
Perceiving and appreciating
this kind of abstract
phenomenon is one of the joys
of being a thinking human
being in this day and age.
And algebra and taxes
and spreadsheets--
they might have turned us off
from numbers, but never forget
that just below the surface,
there's a startling and
magical beauty.
It's just a simple
one, two, three.
You can play with the tool that
I used-- or that I made--
the doodle.
It's at primes.io.
My name's Charlie Deck.
My ID is Bigblueboo.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
LIRON SHER: Good afternoon,
everyone.
My name is Liron Sher.
I'm an Israeli entrepreneur.
I'm here to speak about the
Israeli StartApp ecosystem,
and how it is to be
an entrepreneur.
So I just started my journey
about one year ago.
Of course, I'm from Tel Aviv.
And basically, Tel Aviv is the
capital of StartApp in Israel.
We have some StartApp in Be'er
Sheva and Haifa, but the most
StartApp ecosystem
is in Tel Aviv.
You can see that if you throw a
dime in Tel Aviv, you going
to hit a StartApp.
It may be a StartApp, it
may be an accelerator--
everything you need in order
to be a StartApp,
you have in Tel Aviv.
So come to Tel Aviv.
It's very good for to
make a StartApp.
But in order to make a
StartApp, you have
to get a cool idea.
Everybody in Israel thinks you
have an idea, because we've
been through the army.
We can do everything.
So we think we can
do a StartApp.
But not all the StartApp in
Israel are successful.
Some of them-- most
of them, less.
But you have to have a big
idea in order to get a
StartApp in Israel.
So my first tip for you,
get a good idea.
Do a good idea, so
it can last--
in order to get your StartApp.
And then, before you can go to
the StartApp journey, to be an
entrepreneur, think
about yourself.
Are you up to it?
Can you be an entrepreneur?
Can you do a StartApp?
Can you be a CEO?
Because if you're not
up to it, give up.
Go be a salary man.
But if you can do
it, just do it.
And then, build your A-Team.
Build the one that will
help you to go this
long journey of StartApp.
They have to be a good guy.
They have to be the best guys.
They have to be a tech guy.
Get the guy that will complete
you as you can.
But then, are your partners
up to it?
Find out first that if you have
the tech guy that's very
good in tech, will he help
you do it your way?
Will he be there?
Will his family support
your friend there?
Think about it before you choose
your colleagues through
this long journey.
This is what I can
share with you.
Now find the business model.
You have to find the business
model for your StartApp.
I found four business models
for my StartApp, so I
recommend you to find at
least two business
models for your StartApp.
Otherwise, don't think about
starting developing.
Don't do anything before you
find a business model.
And think about the user.
Will you use your StartApp?
Will you use your application?
Are you going to be the user?
Because if not, give up.
You have to think about the user
and what they're going
earn from using your
application.
Then you look for money.
Every angel can say, hey, you
have a good idea, but show me
some traction, and I will
give you some money.
But then, if I have traction,
why do I need money?
If I have traction, I would
have already the egg.
It's like the chicken
and the egg.
So then you find yourself
bootstrapping.
You leave your company-- you
leave your day to day job and
start bootstrapping
your company.
OK.
What next?
Every day you have to
build something.
And then what do
you want to do?
Then you think about
what is the MVP--
minimum viable product?
Because you cannot build
everything while you are
bootstrapping.
So from one end you have to
be as minimal as you can.
From the end, you have
to get more users in
order to get the money.
So think about what is your MVP
before you go into market.
And then we are doing mobile
application, so we have to
choose what you're going to
do, Android or iPhone.
People are still using iPhone
these days, so you cannot
neglect them, especially
in Israel.
And then you find out that
you want to use HTML5.
One year ago, HTML5 was
very hard to debug.
Also it doesn't work the same
on every iPhone and Android.
You find yourself working
differently
on two Android devices.
So what should you do?
But my app is viral.
So if I develop only for
Android, I will miss half of
the market.
So we decide to develop natively
iPhone and Android at
the same time.
I find myself writing Java code
and x code, and I said
otherwise reversal.
And then we try to
find out backend.
What is the best backend
for you?
I recommend going Google App
Engine, but if you're not a
Python developer or Java
developer, how can you use the
Google App?
That's how it was back then.
So we decided to go to
Amazon Web Services.
So Amazon Web Services
is a great tool.
They have great tools to scale
up, but you have to be an IT
guy in order to work
with Amazon.
So my recommendation for you,
if you're going for Amazon,
just to be an IT guy.
And now we released our MVP.
Our MVP is ready.
We're sending it to
all our customers.
And everybody is saying,
where is this feature,
where is that feature?
And you have to tell your
friends what is MVP, because
nobody except everyone
knows what is MVP.
My name is Liron Sher.
And I hope I've enlightened you
to something about Israel
and StartApps.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BUNNIE: Hi everybody.
I'm Bunnie.
I'm also hailing
from Singapore.
And I'm here to talk to you
today about an ecosystem that
I've been exploring in China
called the gongkai ecosystem.
It's kind of about how ideas
get shared in China,
China-style.
A hobby of mine is I like to go
to Shenzhen, every now and
then and look for wacky
pieces of hardware.
This one here is it looks like
a mouse, except for the
screwed up logo.
But when you go ahead and you
turn it over, you find that on
the inside--
advance slide, advance slide--
there is in fact a full GSM
phone on the inside complete
with a camera.
It makes calls and so forth--
rather funny.
A more serious kind of
application you can find out
there, sort of unique, is
they have this phone
which is for children.
It's a child's safety phone.
It only allows you to dial five
numbers, so your kids
can't text message other
kids in class, and
so on and so forth.
It's an interesting sort
of application of the
technology out there.
Other devices that I have also
found out there that I found
very interesting is this
one, which is a phone.
It looks kind of plain.
But the interesting thing about
it is that it's $12.
And it was kind of
the retail price.
It wasn't with a contract.
Which means that the actual cost
of manufacturing was less
than $12, probably
around $8 or $10.
So of course, I buy it and I
take it apart to see how the
heck they do this.
I find on the inside they've got
a multi 100 megahertz arm
CPU, with 8 megabytes
of memory, a
Bluetooth, quad-band GSM--
all this kind of cool stuff.
And I go, geez, I really want
to build one these.
How do they do this?
So I go on the net and I
start looking around.
And I find I can actually
download the PCB files.
I can download the schematics.
I can go ahead and actually
source the chips in the
markets, and they're only,
like, two bucks.
Why haven't I seen more StartApp
doing this kind of
stuff, is what I wonder.
And when you take a look at the
StartApps that they do in
China, a lot of them are around
phones, whereas in the
US, a lot of the StartApps are
around "app-cessories." They
don't actually build
phones themselves.
They build stuff that
work with phones.
And I wonder is it because
maybe there's no economic
incentive to actually
build phones.
And that's not the case.
There's a company in China
called Xiaomi that was founded
in 2010, and two years later it
was valued at $4 billion,
half that of Nokia.
So clearly there's an economic
incentive to go ahead and
build these kinds of phones.
In fact, the thing is that if
you look at the documentation
you get, they've got
confidential
written all over it.
They have dubious copyright
terms, and so on and so forth.
So in fact, there's an IP
barrier that is presented for
people who are trying to build
these things from the West.
Now this set of terms here,
which we are all very familiar
with, means about as much to the
people in Chinese as if we
were to fill this with Chinese
characters to you.
They don't know, you know,
confidential, DMCA, patents--
all these sorts of things.
They kind of just--
they're in an ecosystem
that is free of
these kinds of things.
So it's interesting
that in China I
can access the designs.
And so the kind of open, and
sort of the end result--
well it's not really open with
the big "O." It's not open in
terms of GPL, or Creative
Commons, or
these kinds of things.
Fortunately in Chinese, they
actually have different words
for big O Open, like Foss, which
is kaifung, and open
with a little "O" which means
you can just sort of share it,
and it's out there.
It's called gongkai.
And in order to sort of
differentiate and sort of-- if
I told people, oh I'm looking
at the open harder ecosystem
in China, people would be
like, you're crazy.
It's not actually open.
So I just call it the gong kai,
harder ecosystem, to sort
of differentiate between what
would be the open ecosystem
versus just a simple open
access ecosystem.
It's interesting to look at
sort of now the kind of
mainstream platforms
per ecosystem.
So in the Western open style,
we have the Ardweno.
It's probably the most
popular one.
It's 15 megahertz CPU you can
buy it for $29 in SparkFun.
And then you go ahead and you
look at the gongkai ecosystem.
And if you remember we have
these devices that are like
200 megahertz and quad-band GSM,
and they cost about $12.
And of course they're not
legally licenses open, but
these schematics, the sharings
of all the blueprints and the
plans through the different
people out there enable them
to go ahead and slot these into
other products, which
enable them to do things, wacky
things, like put a phone
inside of a mouse, or make a
phone with only five buttons
so your kids can use
it, or just sell
outright phones for $12.
So people then ask me-- or
like, kind of the next
question is, how does the system
work in the face of
such theft.
Is it the case that the
consumers are just paying the
entrepreneurs--
thieves, if you will--
and they're taking all the
value, which would be the case
if they were just, like,
stealing software music.
In fact the entrepreneurs have
to rely on the entire value
ecosystem behind them.
They have to rely on contract
manufacturers and brands,
channels, supply chains-- they
have to buy the chips from the
people who they're stealing
the documentation from.
And people have to get
SIM cards with the
carriers and so forth.
So in fact all the players still
make money, it's just
distributed a little
bit differently.
There's a little more money for
the people at the bottom,
and the carriers and the chip
manufacturers don't have quite
as much control.
So that is about the quickest
introduction I can give you to
the gongkai ecosystem.
There's a lot more
stories to tell.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JAISEN MATHAI: Hello
my name is Jaisen.
So let's talk about the
preservation of human history.
And there's something that all
of us in this room have in
common, and it's that
we all have a story.
And as humans, we're actually
natural storytellers.
So I'm going to go into my story
a little bit, and it
starts back with my mother,
back in 1955.
This is a picture of her
family-- her brothers,
sisters, parents, and
grandparents.
Some of these people aren't
even living anymore.
These are not miserable
people.
Indians don't smile in
any photographs.
But this is where
my story starts.
If you fast forward a little bit
to 1981, this is what my
parents would send me out of the
house looking like on the
day that they take
pictures of kids.
You can see the disgust
on my face.
But this is evidence that
I'll show you in a
little bit of something.
This is actually one of my
favorite pictures that I have.
I despise fishing.
I'm not patient enough for it.
But this is a photo of my
father and myself--
apparently I caught something
and it was a picture worthy.
So, fast forward a
little bit more.
This is a photo of me
and my grandfather.
He's passed away, and
he lived in India.
I grew up in the US.
So the time that I did
get to spend with him
was very, very valuable.
And so this is part
of my story.
And I've told it to
a lot of people.
But the interesting thing is,
in 2010, I wasn't just a
storyteller anymore.
I became a story preserver
when I had my son.
And so it really started
changing how I looked at all
this content that I'm taking.
I have a bunch of pictures
of my kids.
But it doesn't start there.
We have to go back, like, 5,000
years, when the ancient
Egyptians were writing
hieroglyphics on the walls of
caves so that future generations
could see them,
little knowing that people would
be devoting their entire
lives 5,000 years later
studying that content.
And it's very sad for me to
stand up here and say that
technology has really failed
us in this aspect.
It's much more easier for us to
capture moments like photos
and videos, but it's more
increasingly easy for us to
lose all of that content
as well.
And so this happens
by-- is users--
what people do is upload all
their content to any number of
service providers.
And in doing so, we then entrust
the service provider
to not only maintain our data,
but to preserve our data.
And the internet, if it's proven
one thing, it's that
that doesn't work.
It's like handing our car keys
to these guys and hoping that
when they're done parking and
bringing it back, that
everything is still in the
glove compartment.
But what if we could actually
write applications in a way
that's different from how we had
done in the past, giving
us something similar to what
car manufacturers do
with a valet key.
And if you're thinking, oh well,
that doesn't actually
solve the problem that
I'm talking about.
And so Albert Einstein
once had a quote.
He said that you cannot change
the problems by using the same
thinking that you did when
you created them.
And so what I'd like to do is
ask all of us to stop thinking
about the way that we've always
developed applications
since the start of
the internet.
This is a photo.
This is really important
stuff.
This is a photo that was found
in the notebook of a soldier
during the Holocaust.
And on the back of it,
it was written,
The Last Jew of Vinnitsa.
This has become one of
the most valuable
artifacts of the Holocaust.
And so--
I lied.
Technology hasn't actually
failed us yet.
But this is where we have to
actually think about writing
applications and services
for users that put data
portability and data ownership
as first class citizens.
And for me I'm most passionate
about the decoupling of data
storage and application logic,
and how that can apply to
software that users
and companies use.
And as a result I started to
open source project called the
Open Photo Project, which
is now called Trovebox.
It's 100% open source.
And the purpose of this is
to provide a service for
individual users and
organizations to allow them to
have 100% data portability
and ownership of
all of their content.
And so we have Android
applications.
We have iPhone applications.
We have a web application.
And an entire API stack and
language findings in every
popular language.
And all of this is available
on GitHub.
And so what we've done is we
started this initially on
Kickstarter.
We went and partnered with
Mozilla as part of the WebFWD
program, and we received funding
from the Shuttleworth
Foundation, which was started
by Mark Shuttleworth.
And we're off to really
great start.
But what I'm here today is to
try to get as many people to
help us, either by participating
in the project
that we've done, or start
thinking about this in the
applications that you build.
How can you decouple data
storage from application
logic, so that when a service
ends up shutting down, all of
your user data doesn't
go along with it.
This is all the information if
you want to chat with me
afterwards, or catch
me on Twitter.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Thank
you very much.
So we've got just one
more speaker.
He's a good friend of mine.
We worked together at Microsoft,
and been to Burning
Man a couple of times.
And this year he's got
two books out.
And so he's here to talk about
your brain on Google.
Please welcome Ramez Naam.
RAMEZ NAAM: Awesome.
Thank you Brady.
My name is Ramez Naam.
I write science fiction.
And I have a novel out that's
about the ultimate Google I/O
The I/O of electronics and data
directly into your brain.
Now you already know about this
topic in your familiarity
with great American
philosophers, like this man--
Keanu Reeves, who said I know
Kung Fu What I'm here to tell
you about is that this is no
longer just science fiction.
It's actually becoming
science fact.
And the motivator is not
Hollywood, it's medicine.
We already have cyborgs
among us.
In particular, a number of
people around the world carry
the cochlear implant.
The cochlear implant looks
like it's a hearing aid.
You'll see a photo of
it in a moment.
But it's not actually
a hearing aid.
It's a device that picks up
sound from the environment
around you, and then bypasses
the ear entirely and beams it
into Keanu over and over and
over and over again.
No, it picks up sound, and
bypasses the ear, actually
transforms sound into nerve
impulses in the auditory nerve
that go straight into the human
brain, unlike a normal
hearing aid that just cleans up
sound and plays backsound.
So it's actually interfacing one
type of data to the brain.
And as a result about 200,000
people around the world, like
this four-year-old girl who is
hearing for the first time,
are now cyborgs who can
hear because we've
learned to do that.
We've also taken data from
inside the brain and sent it
out into digital systems.
This man, Johnny Ray,
was paralyzed by a
stroke, that him--
left him unable to move from the
neck down, unable even to
speak, only able to blink.
But his doctors implanted the
first ever human brain implant
in the motor cortex that allows
him to, by thinking
about it, move a cursor on
an on board screen--
online keyboard--
and type out messages to
his friends and family.
Which is a big quantum leap up
from blinking once for yes and
twice for no.
And now this tech is moving
towards actual approval as a
medical technology.
This woman last year was
implanted with the top of its
line system that allows
her to control a
multi-access robot arm.
And what you see is that she's
feeding herself coffee for the
first time.
We've also sent vision
into the brain.
This man, Jens, was rendered
blind age 19.
At age 40, this cyborg
eye was implanted.
It captures images and then it
sends them into a jack in the
back of his skull, straight
into his visual cortex.
And it restores vision, of
a crappy kind, but a
quantum leap up.
Now humans have more than just
sensory data and motor data.
We also have these
higher functions.
Who here has seen the
film "Memento"?
Some of you.
Well this character Lenny can't
form long term memories
because of damage to part
of his brain called the
hippocampus.
So seeking to fix that, doctors
and scientists have
built a hippocampo
prosthesis--
a chip that simulates that
part of the brain.
And in erratic experiments,
it's able to restore the
memory of rats with brain
damage, and actually go beyond
that and give them
super memory.
These rats learn better than
normal healthy rats.
Now we've gone better to that
and we've gotten into
decision-making and IQ.
These monkeys have had their
performance on a monkey IQ
test-- a pick and match test--
degraded by repeated
doses of cocaine.
They think they've got better,
but they didn't.
But a chip implanted in their
frontal cortex can actually
restore them back to
normal and beyond.
They got about 10 points better
scores on these tests
than normal, healthy monkeys
with this frontal cortex chip,
which of course leads to the
cyborg Planet of the Apes.
Now we don't just use computers
for thinking or
calculating anymore.
We use them as communication
devices.
And that's where this will
become transformative.
Because if we can send data in
and out of one brain, we can
transfer it between
multiple brains.
Now Dartmouth is very
interested in this.
Their Enhanced Battlefield
Communications program has
funded this study, which takes
two monkeys in separate rooms,
sound proof, with electrodes
in their auditory cortices.
And they play a sound for one
monkey, and monkey two can
hear that sound and can
identify what it is.
In humans, we've even put
people in FMRI machines.
We've shown them images like the
one on the left, and the
image on the right is
reconstructed by an algorithm
looking at the brain scan,
and nothing else.
It's not very good yet, but you
can kind of see that it
can tell what's going on.
And the folks who brought you
enhanced rat memory are
working on wiring together
memory chips from two
different rat brains to see if
they can really get to the
point where a rat can
say, I know Kung Fu.
Now there are many, many,
many hurdles to this.
Voluntary brain surgery is
not that common yet.
It's going to be a while
until it's good enough.
And there's questions.
What if it crashes?
I mean, no computers
are perfect.
What if you get a virus?
No computers are
totally secure.
What if you get malware
or a phishing scam?
Those are all very
good questions.
But I think the biggest
questions
actually are societal.
Who gets to control
this technology if
it's in your head?
Is it a bottoms up thing?
Can we hack it ourselves?
Do we own the data?
Or is it top down--
imposed on us.
Can someone snoop on our
thoughts or worse?
So those are the fun questions
I get to attack in the novel.
I hope you'll check it out.
And I look forward to a true
super Google I/O one day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY FORREST: Thank
you very much, Mez.
And that concludes Ignite.
Thank you all for coming.
Thank you Google for
hosting us again.
And you can find these videos
later at Ignite show and on
our Twitter feed.
Cheers.